all right everyone scared from the slow
mo guys I want to show you this video
because I thought it was probably the
coolest thing I've ever filmed by
accident I was outdoors with a macro
lens trying to capture some slow-mo
insect flight there's a bee falling off
a flower which I thought was pretty
funny I wonder how often that happens in
nature anyway this is why I want to show
you it's a damselfly sitting on a leaf
and I've shrunk it down so you can see
what I was seeing at the time through
the viewfinder you see there just flies
away and when I went to play it back on
the big screen I realized that actually
filmed something way more cool you can
probably see it already if you're
watching an HD there's a little fly in
the middle of the screen like a little
gnat not sure what that actually is but
it turns out this damselfly wasn't just
flying off it was well getting lunch I
guess
I just couldn't believe I film that the
fact that it was you know happened right
in front of the lens and completely in
focus as well so lucky and that's it
thanks for watching this be sure to
subscribe for more slow-mo